tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo video
sono fa vj e oggi siamo su qualche
computer
finally a safe place to manage ring ma
prima c'è scritto che è un posto sicuro
per poter controllare la propria rabbia
e scaraventare gli oggetti per
distruggere il computer è in base alla
bellezza di questo gioco potrei sfondare
il mio quindi cerchiamo di capirci prima
di tutti i ragazzi vediamo di cominciare
perché sa cosa mi ha messo abbastanza
curiosità ma se non so chi so io mica il
figo che sono uno gnocco della madonna
nera ma buongiorno bravo zio conquista
la come si deve forza e coraggio e ha
rotto i [ __ ] computer professore di
nuovo però c'è il computer che
[ __ ] dai ce la puoi fare
un attimo di pazienza ragazzi stava
elaborando un attimino le mie tattiche
da da gentleman seduttore di quella
[ __ ] [ __ ] è un po come se tentasse
di rimorchiare mia madre mi mandasse la
lista della spesa abbiamo una barca
[ __ ] e fax
bellissima e picchiato ragazzi sta
diventando una roba isterica cioè mio
dio
intervengo io ragazzi perché se non
intervengo sta tizia se ne va a casa
quindi capiamoci la porta io posso più
cosa fa è scappato a casa
cazzola ha preso qualche buu match cazzo
vita che mira è un eroe click ma do a
era un sogno ma [ __ ] bellissimo
gymnova benefit questa una genialata il
computer continua rompere i cogl erano
andiamo di telefono che mi sembra cosa
migliore chi sto chiamando di preciso la
disinfestazione per il tele per i
computer ho capito affetto tutto chiaro
io non ripetere perché ho capito tutto
cosa cazzo è quella roba lì
a posto ha posto oggi ma che bravo fred
flinstone complimenti secondo me potevi
semplicemente chiudere il computer però
tranquillo va bene uguale sono dodici
tra le cose che posso farlo
perfetto perché ma poi fare il [ __ ]
la pasta va a chiuderlo cioè non no non
ha senso
i ragazzini di sedia no la scarpa con la
madonna
cosa ti ha fatto dopo la tua risata a me
è venuto dritto oa ragione che per
ragazzi la cosa strana è che sta
continuando a sognare cose perché sono
episodi che lui sogna sogni di continuo
cioè tipo inception tacco nemmeno questo
[Musica]
madonna recenti peak calibro non puoi
tirarlo su quindi mi dispiace della
serie della serie porca [ __ ] che mira
se non vuoi portare la statua dal
computer portiamo il compiuta dalla
stata complimenti sia trasferita guarda
che bel e boccia tutte parte gr web
complimenti addominali scolpiti un pene
duro a questo castello del nero è una
c'è mai un padrone
aveva un fottutissimo bazooka nel muro
spiegatemi ad ala fissa innamora tizia
sempre innamorato non ne frega un cazzo
è normale tutti abbiamo almeno un
bazooka nel muro perché chi è che tra
l'altro è sempre più figo comunque
ragazzi proseguiamo perché non ho ancora
capito questo le spade yo yo subito
allora se [ __ ] nell'anima del
cervello cioè fatemi capire rope h cosa
fai
mi affetti il pallino zio bravissimi i
complimenti questa l'interpretazione da
10 da oscar pensare che c'è anche una
cos'è sta roba su un pezzo di immobile
con l'arco porca [ __ ] che mira mi
comincia in ammira che non hai idea
spero che tu sappia centrale tutti i
buchi perché se non sarebbe capovolto
questa regione comunque l'asian perda
ragazzi andiamo avanti che questo sogno
mi mancava la sua bella faccia senza non
poteva andare avanti non ci riuscivo che
sanno fare ancora mi piacciono i nostri
pochissima questo un pezzo di quadro
ragazzi una tra i no no abbassa sto
cazzo di pennarello ascolto a giro buca
1 perfetto qualcuno che ci ha stupiti ha
beccato una vecchietta in testa ed è
morta c'è però una bella non c'è più
niente al pesce ragazzi pesce non ci
credo fermi natio questo dovevo 20 ma
subito è una roba del tipo che fa si sta
facendo vuole salvare il perno dimmi che
sarà il pesce bravo ragazzo mi piace per
questa scena però poi lui e un cognome
quindi va bene si bilanciano le cose i
complimenti e nei è sempre più
innamorata e lui è sempre più marcio a
compimento il pesce sempre più sexy
pesce l'unica cosa colorata nella stanza
tranne la scritta
vabbè ho già fatto tutto cosa vuole
ancora questo c'è ancora quanti
sportelli ciò in sostanza non piace cosa
hai trovato zio ma molto set
una motosega non come
[Musica]
c'è la tizia rischiato di perdere delle
gambe ma ok siamo all'ultimo ragazzi non
ho idea di dove cazzo si sa però ce l'ho
adesso lo trovo spesa n'attimo ci sarà
scritto da qualche parte nei pozzi non
lo sto trovando buongiorno zia
complimenti per aver messo la tua foto
sotto a chi your computer c'è una roba
geniale nati in specie ai agri era un
altro cristo di sportello ma [ __ ]
a mezz'ora per la saga gara vera
imboscati si sia infilato un petardo nel
culo anno l'ha tirato fondo perfetto
non credo entri nel vabbè
ha vinto perché la sec saggini di
quest'uomo è qualcosa di incredibile che
cosa sta facendo set hard
la mappa minchia che in casi occhio al
computer un gioco molto ma molto ma
molto intelligente e soprattutto vedendo
la faccia di sta tizia l'unica cosa
ragazzi che il video sto cristiano sono
i capelli
giuro comunque ragazzi con colombi
l'episodio spero che walking il computer
vi sia piaciuto era l'ultimo wac
esistente non ce ne sono più e rapimenti
all'ultimo però valeva la pena di farlo
solo per il vestito della tizia che fa
veramente vomitare è quindi ragazzi
concluso vile episodio cosa sento se
video è piaciuto è stato momento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e con
il video tratta descrizione se volete
anche voi un computer che sia resistente
ai petardi lasciato un mi piace anche un
petardone civile diavolo prossimo vita e
l'aria
[Musica]